Scientists are working hard to make cows,
sheep, and goat farts less harmful to the
planet .
In 2015 agricultural researchers fed sheep
seaweed, and as a result, their farts and
belches contained 70 percent less methane.
In 2016, another group gave garlic to cows
and found a 50 percent reduction in methane.
There are 1.5 billion cows in the world, chewin’,
belchin’, fartin’ and poopin’, and each
cow can produce up to 500 liters of methane
per day!
That’s comparable to the amount of methane
from an average car.
Once in the atmosphere, methane helps keep
the planet warm, making it one of the major
culprits behind climate change.
Reducing methane can drastically affect climate
change.
In the wild, cows would eat grasses and a
bit of grain.
They break down all that grass with the help
of microorganisms called archaea in their
four-chambered stomachs.
Some of the archaea produce methane -- those
are called methanogens.
This also applies to other animals that have
chambered stomachs, like sheep and goats -- more
methanogens, more methane!
To reduce the number of methanogens, agricultural
researchers have tried selective breeding
and feeding animals fats and starches to help
curb their farting.
These methods did not work as well as feeding
cows garlic and onions.
There’s a problem though… if you give
a cow an onion, it’s going to produce onion
flavored milk.
And this is the case with other strong flavors
like garlic.
And for most milk-drinkers, garlic milk or
onion milk probably don’t sound too appealing.
So even though we know these stinky foods
reduce the methane… the flavor of the milk
stops us from putting it into practice.
One study has proved promising.
Scientists in Spain fed cows low levels of
propyl propane thiosulfonate, the compound
in onions which gives them their strong flavor.
By giving them 25 grams per day of PTSO, they
could inhibit methanogens and keep the milk
mostly tasty.
Only 12.5 percent of milk tasters sensed onion…
The researchers joked the garlic milk might
be good for the french cheese industry, but
for now, this is still a work in progress.
And as global warming accelerates, be sure
scientists will keep working to cut back on
the amount of methane ballooning from the
bowels our bovine buddies.